[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle vise la présidence de la région
ile-de-france valérie pécresse la chef
de file ump dans les yvelines organise à
poissy ce soir un meeting sur le thème
notre île de france 2000 vingt sixième
rendez vous de ce type neuf sont prévus
au programme transports logement emploi
ce qui lui permettra d'élaborer son
programme les élections régionales
pourrait se tenir fin 2015
les invités de ce journal à présent le
commandant des pompiers philippe casarin
bonsoir qu'elle souhaite chef du secteur
de commandement de montigny le
bretonneux chef du centre de secours
principal de montigny et chloé nous
répond soir si vous êtes sapeurs
pompiers volontaires au sein du centre
de secours principal donc là montigny le
bretonneux on va parler des portes
ouvertes dans votre caserne qui vont se
dérouler le 14 juin plus précisément
elle de la vocation aussi et de la crise
peut-être de la vocation dans votre
profession
elle met déjà concernant les intempéries
de ce week end les orages qui ont
traversé l ile de france ces dernières
nuits ont occasionné de nombreux dégâts
est ce que ça a été le cas sur votre
secteur plutôt le sud du département
merci déjà de nous accueillir ce soir en
effet le territoire et blinois a été
traversé par deux phénomènes orageux
d'un important dans la nuit de dimanche
à lundi et lundi en journée
essentiellement sur le territoire du
mantois et sur le secteur de saint
germain en laye pour la partie de la
communauté d'agglo de saint quentin en
yvelines
il ya eu peu d'interventions une
vingtaine environ qui ont été
occasionnés à l'occasion de ces deux
événements orageux laquelle nature cas
type d'intervention alors
essentiellement des toitures endommagées
des caves inondées qui ont occasionné
donc petite trentaine d'interventions
c'est une situation habituelle on te
fait qu'ils peuvent produire ce genre de
choses avec les orages commencent à
s'organiser juste qu'on comprenne bien
c'est la préfecture qui pilote qui vont
mobilise qui peut éventuellement vous
demander d'aller en renfort sur l'autre
côté du département par exemple en
justement pour revenir sur le mantois et
saint-germain-en-laye 500 interventions
ont été répertoriées à l'occasion de ses
quarante huit heures qui ont mobilisé
des moyens départementaux
tout au long de l'année en effet les
sapeurs pompiers se prépare à faire face
à ce genre d'événement et nous exerçons
à travers des manoeuvres des exercices
pour être les meilleurs lorsqu'une
intervention à caractère multiple se
produit donc vous êtes parti sur le côté
du mans trois noms pour cet événement
pas partie est ce donc la préfecture qui
pilote qui vous alerte qui est qu'il
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
notre patron opérationnel est en effet
le préfet des yvelines dont il peut
décider de répartir les moyens de façon
la plus juste possible pour répondre aux
interventions
ça n'a pas été le cas pour ce week-end
vous êtes venus ce soir avec une
pompiers volontaires pour évoquer un
autre sujet ce sont les portes ouvertes
au centre de secours de montigny le
bretonneux histoire elle de présenter
votre travail en cette journée du 4 ans
se joint aussi susciter des vocations
chloé nour et avec quel est votre
parcours vous avec les les pompiers vous
êtes engagé quand alors moi j'ai été
jeune sapeur-pompier donc jsp pendant
quatre années le mercredi après midi
après les cours
suivez une formation en parallèle de mes
études qui m'a permis de prendre ensuite
des gardes depuis maintenant deux ans
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie d'être
volontaire le côté militaire j'irai plus
où ils côté discipline et la rigueur
l'activité physique et voilà vous êtes
sapeurs pompiers volontaires
c'est-à-dire que vous avez une
profession à côté alors à côté je suis
en études de staps à la faculté d'orsay
dans l'essonne vous arrivez à concilier
les deux emplois du temps c'est parfois
difficile mais quand on aime ça c'est un
petit peu la difficulté d'arriver à
concilier les deux elle est encore en
étude mais lorsqu'on travaille mon
professionnels acceptent moins
facilement c'est peut-être ce qui
explique aussi quelquefois les
difficultés à trouver des sapeurs
pompiers volontaires alors tout dépend
du territoire sur lequel on situe en
milieu urbain comme c'est le cas à
montigny-le-bretonneux
on n'a pas de grandes difficultés à
recruter des vampires volontaire
certaines unités opérationnelles en
milieu rural elles ont plus de
difficulté plus de problèmes parce qu'il
ya moins de personnes - demont de
disponible pour répondre aux
sollicitations et surtout
pour pouvoir réaliser d'une part la
formation qui aurait tellement
conséquente et qui permet d'assurer un
haut niveau de réponse opérationnelle
qui et qui ensuite
enfin pour trouver des personnes qui
sont disponibles pour répondre aux
sollicitations sollicitations pardon
opérationnel donc crise des vocations
tout dépend du territoire chloé est un
est un bel exemple de ceux de la
représentation qu'on peut se faire d'un
pompier volontaire
elle est issue du cursus des jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers donc c'est une
association qu'on accueille au sein de
l'unité
donc on peut s'engager très jeune oui à
partir de quel âge à partir de 10 ans
sous forme associatifs sont des jeunes
qui viennent au mercredi qui s'entraîne
aux gestes de secours aux techniques
d'un 110 pour se préparer à devenir
pompier volontaire donc et chloé le bel
exemple d'une femme et j'ai les pompiers
bac c'est un bac s universitaire et qui
poursuit son engagement au service des
autres au sein magasin de
montigny-le-bretonneux
vous l'avez souligné alors forcément je
vais rebondir dessus on l'avait dit une
femme qui s'engagent pour les pompiers
c'est assez rare finalement est ce que
vous êtes nombreuses à montigny on va
dire qu'on est et quatre
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires sur une
soixantaine quand même j'ai commencé
perçu par votre entourage
lorsque vous avez dit d'une part je veux
m'engager pour les pompiers puis d'autre
part à lorsqu'il fallut qu'il ya qu il
réalise qu'il n'y aura pas forcément
beaucoup de femmes qui seraient présents
alors oui ils ont eu peur clément mais
bon ça se passe bien au sein de la
caserne ya pas de souci est que tout le
monde tout le monde cohabite bien non il
appartient aux sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et volontaires féminin ou
masculin de répondre à ce défi avec
efficacité leurs missions donc encore
une fois ce n'est pas le sexe ou le
statut qu'on regarde c'est bien
l'engagement la disponibilité et la
volonté de servir les autres et quelles
sont les missions qui sont confiées aux
les mêmes que les poncifs conditionnelle
oui les pompiers volontaires ont une
formation rigoureuse et soutenu qu'ils
leur permettre qui leur permet de pardon
de l'acquérir des compétences
opérationnelles et au même titre que
leurs collègues professionnels ils
partent sur les mêmes interventions
quelles sont les interventions qui vous
ont marqué est-ce qu'il ya intervention
oui on en mémoire à un accouchement
forcément donner la vie ça c'est
marquant
s'ils ont des pompiers qui sont
effectivement très très larges très
vaste cette profession est elle mal
reconnus et elle pas assez en tout cas
reconnu c'est la question que nous
sommes allez vous poser aujourd'hui
c'est notre micro trottoir du jour je
pense qu'il faudrait en parler davantage
valorisé un peu plus cette profession la
dynamiser et parce que le public a
besoin de connaître un petit peu mieux
les tâches des pompiers
c'est pas qu'on entend parler des
pompiers pour parler d'une catastrophe
en particulier mais pas forcément de
leur métier allez c'est sûr qu'ils
risquent quand même beaucoup l'envié je
pense que son passé au bien représentés
ils ont une notoriété reconnue c'est une
population qui est un qui apprécié dans
la cité notamment des consciences un
pompier
c'est un moment qui va sur eux au feu et
c'est normal c'est sa vocation
personne ne l'obligent de le faire je
pense que globalement on apprécie cette
profession est parce qu elle rend des
missions très très utile au pays à la
nation et aux habitants profession
apprécié des français mais ce qu'elle
est suffisamment reconnue est ce que l
est sapeur pompier volontaire est ce que
ne serait ce que le gouvernement fait
suffisamment pour faciliter et
encourager les vocations
bien entendu il y a une politique de
développement du volontariat l'échelon
national qui rit relayé à l'échelon
départemental
donc tout est mis en oeuvre pour
reconnaître et développer le volontariat
concernant justement le caractère
enfin la reconnaissance de notre
profession régulièrement les sondages
nous placent en tête des professions les
plus les plus reconnus al'inverse des
journalistes et voilà il l'occasion de
cette journée portes ouvertes et je
rebondis là dessus c'est d'un certain
côté ouvrir nos portes pour remercier la
population de l'accueil et la confiance
qu'ils nous accordent là toute l'année
ça sera une journée de fête que vous
allez organiser le 14 juin ça permettra
d'évoquer les différentes facettes de ce
métier comment ça va se dérouler alors
une journée de fête jeunes et festive
mais malgré tout professionnel
l'objectif encore une fois c'est
d'ouvrir nos portes à la population du
territoire pour qu'ils viennent
découvrir notre nos spécialités de
spécialités culinaires nos spécialités
professionnelles tablier vous n'avez pas
sur les maîtres chiens les sauveteurs
animalier le grimp etc tout est tourné
ou également autour de l'atelier
dynamique
il y aura des tyroliennes pour les
enfants des parcours sportifs des
parcours de sapeurs-pompiers des
baptêmes de plongée et également pour
rentrer plus au coeur du métier ben on
va simuler des interventions de la
désincarcération de l' incendie
voilà autant de autant d'activités qui
doivent permettre de satisfaire le plus
grand nombre de buts 7 créer des
vocations aussi bien entendu
d'encourager c'est les plus jeunes à
vous rejoindre
c'est une idée objective de cette
journée vous allez intervenir sur cette
journée sur un accident de la route
et quand le 15 mai salle vous allez
faire passer comment vous allez
convaincre justement ces familles qui
vont venir avec leurs enfants de
s'engager
quel message vous vous avez passé
puisque vous allez être en contact
direct avec eux aider les autres
ça permet de s'épanouir soi même chose
comment vous voyez votre évolution au
sein des pompiers
vous allez rester encore longtemps est
ce qu'on peut évoluer est-ce qu'on peut
passer de volontaires à professionnel je
peux très bien passé un concours pour
passer professionnel vous faire mon vrai
métier je sais tu pas dans mon optique
pour le moment je me trouve jeunes mais
c'est c'est possible je vous ai pas
demandé votre âge âgés 18 ans vous avez
18 ans est engagé donc depuis depuis dix
ans depuis 16 ans je suis volontaire et
j'ai commencé à 13 ans dans quatre
jeunes sapeurs pompiers pour faire la
formation vous allez à votre avis ont
retrouvé encore beaucoup des comme ça ce
week-end nous engager ausy jeunes enfin
je l'espère c'est également l'objectif
de cette journée mais et chloé la traîne
a souligné très justement le message à
faire passer c'est pour être
sapeur-pompier professionnel ou
volontaire c'est avant toute chose un
engagement au service de la nation et au
service des autres ils sont
régulièrement ils sont soumis sont
nombreux à passer le cap et à passer de
bénévolat à professionnels nous
organisons au sein de l'unité
opérationnelle que je commande trois
sessions de recrutements par an est en
effet les pompiers volontaires qui le
souhaitent peuvent passer le concours de
sapeur-pompier professionnel ça concours
qui est difficile et voilà après il faut
il faut être écoutés voix merci à tous
les deux est revenu sur cette photo on
rappelle un ses portes ouvertes au
centre de secours à montigny le
bretonneux 14 juin à partir de 10h
jusqu'à 17h merci encore santé à présent
la chromothérapie ou comment se soigner
par la couleur une technique qui se
développe et qui se base sur l'idée que
les couleurs ont un réel impact sur le
corps et le cerveau le test avec yolande
thorez attend d'une inflammation à
l'épaule
yannick se rend régulièrement dans ce
nouveau cabinet à thoiry
d'accord donc on va retravailler sur sur
votre épaule pour l'attendre évite donc
une petite demi-heure à agir sur
l'épaule se soigner par la couleur c'est
ce que propose de stéphanie fort à
travers des séances de chromothérapie si
nos yeux voilés couleur il faut savoir
que celle-ci traverse également tout le
reste de notre corps chaque couleur a
une longueur d'onde différentes et
peut-être alors utilisé pour influencer
nos cellules vivantes dans le bon sens
donc j'ai choisi la couleur en fonction
de ce que je veux faire sur le corps je
choisis mon point est ma couleur
et donc je change de tout est géré par
l'ordinateur je change sur l'ordinateur
la couleur de la lente la couleur du
stylo en fonction effectivement de ce
que je veux faire
stress fatigue problèmes de surpoids
troubles du sommeil ou encore douleurs
articulaires la chromothérapie peut
guérir de nombreux problèmes du
quotidien pour soigner sa tendinite et
yannick combine son traitement
médicamenteux
avec ces séances de médecine douce au
bout dans mon sens quand même peut-être
une
chaleur qui arrivait au niveau du point
sensible sinon il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas de ressentir particulier sur le
coup mais mais comme vous il ya une
sensation d'amélioration et de qui vient
assez rapidement après la séance
en france il ne serait pas plus d'une
quinzaine d'experts est depuis le début
de l'année stéphanie fort est la seule à
proposer des séances de ce type dans les
yvelines
ça c'est notre cercle chromatique donc
on travaille avec 12 couleurs justes 12
et chaque couleur est relié à un
méridien et après ça on sait parce que
c'est de la médecine chinoise qui ça
exige depuis 5000 ans que le méridien
agit sur telle émotion telle partie
psychique est elle partie du corps une
école franco suisse enseigne la
chromothérapie depuis 30 ans déjà
pourtant cette pratique reste encore
assez méconnue sur notre territoire
les gens pour l'instant c'est vrai on
encore l'idée que le médecin peut tout
faire
là maintenant effectivement ils
s'aperçoivent que c'est pas le cas que
certains médicaments ne sont pas bons
pour la santé
donc il commence à s'orienter vers les
médecines douces en général maintenant
la chromothérapie comme effectivement on
est très peu à exercer ça reste quelque
chose qui qui est en découvertes
comptez environ 60 euros pour une séance
d'une heure samedi 7 juin se tenait la
12e édition du festival escales
d'ailleurs au château de plaisir dans ce
concert et arts de rue se mêlaient pour
le bonheur du public avec pour
thématique cette année la méditerranée
olivier maniscalco est clair qu'en
billets pour les images
les cultures du monde sous toutes leurs
formes pour sa douzième édition le
festival escales d'ailleurs réunissait
ce week-end musiciens danseurs artistes
de rue et public au parc du château de
plaisir sur le thème de la méditerranée
cette année le rendez vous a offert une
variété de spectacles aux influences
orientales
il ya des richesses très forte au niveau
de l'espagne au niveau d'italie au
niveau du maghreb et on a eu la chance
en plus de rencontrer toute une série
d'artistes qui méritait vraiment qu'il
soit invité ici et donc on a eu entre
les marionnettes de syracuse
et puis là-bas les musiciens trapéziste
italien j'avoue que c'était elle et
danse aussi grecques qu'on a pu voir
c'était vraiment très très riches comme
tu crois que le choix était évident
qu'ils en avaient besoin encore plus de
soleil donc pourquoi pas la méditerranée
une bonne ambiance à des concerts du
théâtre ou des marionnettes géantes le
public avait l'embarras du choix
et avec le pôle jeux même les petits
n'avaient pas le temps de s'ennuyer
sans parler de joie de jeu qu'on n'a pas
forcément chez nous n'a vu les musiques
n'est parti voir deux expositions
ça montre qu'on peut faire de la musique
avec n'importe quoi on a écouté de la
musique on a vu les gens danser on a
fait des petits jeux parce que j'aime
bien c'est que ça réunit pas mal de
personnes donc la petite culture
différente et
si elle soleil c'est encore mieux cette
année encore près de dix mille personnes
ont participé aux festivités sport
c'était ce week end également la
compagnie d'arc d'elancourt qui
organisait un concours extérieurs
sélectifs pour les championnats de
france parmi les quelques 400 archers
présents la nouvelle championne du monde
sophie dodémont était venu à décocher
quelques flèches anthony rech
depuis son titre mondial à nîmes il ya
deux mois
sophie dodemont est désormais très
attendu sur les pâtir c'est la fierté du
pays
elle est reconnue à l'international a
gagnent tout et concours qu'elle fait en
première mondiale enfin vous n'y a pas
longtemps qu'on classique et une
première saison en arc à poulies elle a
battu tout le monde
à 40 ans et pour seulement sa deuxième
saison en arc à poulies sophie dodemont
a décroché son premier titre
international et enchaîné il ya trois
semaines en battant le record d'europe
du nombre de points inscrits en
extérieur aujourd'hui je me pose la
question qu'est ce qui manque au corps
comme tout sportif un certain niveau
c'est vrai que voilà mon classique j'ai
fait du classique avenches une médaillée
olympique ma carrière sportive commence
à être bien remplie
ça fait plaisir malgré cette excellence
la sociétaire du club de villiers-le-bel
n'est pas parvenu à se qualifier pour
les phases finales des dernières étapes
de coupe du monde
une preuve du niveau du plateau
international actuel aujourd'hui on est
vraiment sur un tir de précision surtout
un arc à poulies qu'on voit les sommes
tous des matches qui font 150 150 à 50
mètres ils sont départagées à la plus
belle flèche à au centre 11e' mais c'est
super impressionnant
membre de l'équipe de france depuis 25
ans sophie de demont semble bien décidé
à ne pas ranger ses flèches et tire
désormais après le record du monde du
nombre de points en fin de journal de ce
dit je vous retrouve mercredi en direct
à 18h 19h pour la première rediffusion
très bonne soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]